um magnus kept wesley waiting now
wesley's keeping magnus waiting we do
have the first move on the board though
wesley opens with his king's pawn
in the last final back in february when
these two met wesley had a lot of
success with this king spawn
openings he'd recommended on a chessable
course but meanwhile magnus opening with
his king's pawn as well
in reply will we see wesley do something
we've seen him play before
does he have a surprise in store for
like well this is already a move that he
recommended in
his own chesapore course and
now if the queen's pawn moves two
squares that is his course
recommendation so uh this is gonna be
fascinating stuff
first time round so this is the italian
game it's a very direct way of playing
the italian game but first time round a
few months ago wesley won
this position against magnus carlsen i
do think magnus
won't be surprised this time round
however magnus will have done his
homework
white has an extra central pawn right
now but black is ahead in development
black has castled his king
so this is well-known stuff white tends
to be
just trying to clamp down gain space in
the center keep that as long as possible
black will try and counter attack at
this point because they have
faced each other in this opening before
okay
but now he's made a change okay but he
shook his head when he did that
looking a bit distracted there wesley so
i've got two or three sensible moves
here let's just work it out
there we go magnus does retreat his
bishop so he spent quite a long time
there
and playing the most common move white
bringing the queen to the left side and
now i think the best move here for black
is actually to bring
his knight to the side of the board to
attack that white queen
and this is something i've had myself
okay he retreats with the knight white
castling his king okay
so just a normal game now it's all going
to slow down and become about
maneuvering i do slightly prefer white's
chances and the evaluation bar
slightly prefers white's chances because
white occupies the center
with more pawns white has more space
because this is the main move
and there you can see it and now here
the most principal move
is actually to undermine the head of
white's pawn chain
oh we have a move wow he does come up
with a very odd move after that
huge think by magnus now more than 10
minutes behind on the clock he just
brings his rook across one square
that rook is blocked in on that line it
does defend a pawn meaning that black's
bishop black's dark square bishop is
free to move
white's queen will no longer attack
pawns on that b line but
that's a purely defensive move and if
white brings the knight to the energy
aboard which he has done you predicted
the future ivanka white's knight eyeing
up this bishop at least
magnus now he has the opportunity to
just move that bishop away from the
attack he can retreat that bishop
you could also maybe find a more active
square uh okay he does retreat the
bishop to safety
and now wow look at these we say knights
on the rim are dim
but look at these two knights both of
them finding the edge of the board
um yeah knights on the side we do not
abide magnus has to come up with
something to save it now
and he tries to save it by pushing his
pawn forward so if white attacks the
knight the knight at least
has somewhere to run back to the knight
would be protected on that square by a
pawn
fix look at wesley's air quality that is
perfect air quality
right now uh co2 levels humanity
temperature everything
great for wesley maybe black can even
get away with this but no magnus doesn't
want to allow this
and instead wants to counter-attack he
allows that to happen in the center
now countering its counter-attacking
against white's knight on the edge of
the board
meanwhile white's knight that was
attacked on this side of the board we
did mention one of the top
um top options for wesley so was just
just simply
remove that knight from the fire of
black's pawn we seek clarification and
they we see it magnus has chosen that
move and i'm expecting
him to capture i think with the queen
is what i'm going to say oh okay he
throws in a little bit of a
intermediate move um porn takes pawn
attacking the knight
we actually have a word for this in uh
chess talk
the other move the computer suggests
will not happen wow
okay i was going to say magnus will not
bring his bishop to this square but he
brings his bishop to this one
instead magnus carson coming up with a
really creative move there
see these stats every player every
person is different right in the home
office and
okay meanwhile wesley does capture that
night with his pawn as expected
and magnus ticking down on his clock
i can see kyle you've got you've seen a
result yeah
that's correct after 35 seconds game
three between yonder pogniacci and timur
jabo was finished
with a draw so they have now played
three games all draws
what do you guys expect from the fourth
one well i hear some of this i
i know i'm well i don't bet but i know
what i would put my
my money on meanwhile there has been a
lot of action magnus carson did bring
his queen up to attack
to threaten checkmate as we predicted in
a different scenario
and that was blocked white's bishop now
blocking and the black queen having to
sidestep
white has captured one of black's
bishops so suddenly if we do account
material is still level material on the
board is still equal
but it's opposite color bishops black
has a very very strong bishop
in white's half of the board white
bishop attacked had to step back
attacking
black's queen you do like this
transition
for who do you prefer in this position
after all those traits
personally i would yeah i would just
take that bishop as he has done that
bishop was just
too well placed and i'm curious now how
he will react
and uh well he
he is a super grand master for a reason
and there he just
calmly walks his queen or one a square
forward
would not have dreamt of that move at
all i mean to me
it's just like it removes the connection
from the queen getting to
the right it's highly surprising right
that wesley has pushed his queen up
there he's going after black's pawns on
that left side but magnus he's giving up
his pawns
look at the black rooks now and the
black queen they're all lined up
together
it's looking like there's going to be
some threats you mentioned earlier
ivanka that black's threats might take
through
oh now there's a big threat wow what's
happening with the bar night coming in
i mean is there a threat to um sorry
knight square to um to the center
okay just to sacrifice itself yeah let's
actually let's bring up the analysis
board because suddenly
it does look like wesley so he's
underestimated black's attack uh if yeah
let's keep an eye on the players that
he might react soon wesley so if he gets
greedy and takes his pawn which must
have been his intention then black's
knight would jump in
to this square threatening checkmate and
after pawn takes knight suddenly the
queen takes
white's king is just under heavy fire
when the king moves blacks
rooks are going to enter the position
next turn so wesley tried to stop that
he tried to defend that square and now
the pawn is coming
uh whoops instead of queen takes points
alright wesley did bring his rook across
and now look at this magnus just so calm
okay so we do have a move he's advanced
his pawn so the i mean what's his
responsive uh black word to just to push
one square further yeah we will see
magnus push his pawn one square further
just to loosen up
white's king uh shelter even more there
we go
yeah i mean this is we've said in the
past it is kind of alpha zero
influenced by ai and this type of idea
with black but it's just good chess it's
just pushing a pawn or weakening your
opponent's king
using the pawn as a battering ram now
wesley so takes a pawn but that pawn
looks irrelevant
white's queen is just not joining the
action we got an explosive move david we
have a tactic
on the board magnus is willing to
sacrifice
a knight just to open up
the white king position and it's going
to be checkmate oh
we have to show this mate yeah we will
go back and show this actually magnus
was ready to sacrifice his queen
um if something different had happened
there but okay wesley tried to trade off
a set of rooks but that's not going to
help him
magnus pushing a pawn white's rook has
to move and then it's just going to be
checkmate
wesley so he's either losing a rook or
he's getting checkmated he just resigns
wow what a dramatic start to the final
magnus carlsen almost getting a check
mate here
and winning the first game with the
black pieces